je déclare ouvert ce premier festival de
deauville du cinéma américain 1975 pour
la première fois deauville accueille un
festival du cinéma américain
mais pourquoi ce cinéma en particulier
selon certains détracteurs il n'avait
pas besoin de promotion car déjà
omniprésent dans les salles de cinéma
françaises
faux selon les organisateurs du festival
et son âge
décès de faire connaître le cinéma
américain en france mais le cinéma
américain dont on ignore
car finalement dans une allée en france
et même en europe on voit peut-être 10%
de ce qui est produit aux états unis
donc l'idée est l'objectif de ce
festival est de faire venir des films
indépendant defender town
gestion des films de télévision que le
public n'aurait pas du tout l'occasion
pour cette première édition 50 films
sont présentés
nashville de robert altman ou encore
janice retraçant la vie de janis joplin
contrairement à d'autres festivals dans
un premier temps deauville ne remettez
pas de prix de quoi charmer le parrain
de la première édition et nous avons
accepté de parrainer sens que j'ai
horreur des décorations mais les comités
de quel qu'il soit outre le monde du
cinéma
les deux villes est aussi apprécié ce
nouveau festival cette année c'est la
première année donc il faut le temps que
ça démarre
je crois que c'est une idée fantastique
et que l'année prochaine ce sera
vraiment un grand festival et pour la
station leur entrée sur le faire revivre
c'est près de paris dans mon plaisir
bonne initiative et oui car au delà d'un
festival de cinéma c'est une bonne
opération commerciale organisé début
septembre
il permet de prolonger la saison
touristique en normandie et de trouver
un nouveau public
pari gagnant si la première édition
avait attiré 500 personnes c'est
aujourd'hui en moyenne soit 5000
spectateurs par édition le groupe
barrière est d'ailleurs le principal
partenaire et ça depuis le début le pdg
expliqué des années plus tard
l'intérêt du festival c'est au sol vous
permettre d'apprendre les américains car
faire la publicité à l'amérique sait pas
où je vais le dire ça coûte des fortunes
ne sommes très pas ça ne serait pas
possible aujourd'hui le festival
valorise toujours le cinéma indépendant
américain
mais il s'est rapproché du
fonctionnement des autres grands
festivals en décernant un grand prix
depuis 1995
[Musique]
paris